ستمتد الحرب شهورا طويله وتكلفتها اكبر
بكثير مما كان مخططا هذا ما قاله نتنياهو
في جلسه صاخبه للحكومه الاسرائيليه عقدت
لمناقشه ميزانيه العام الجديد بعد مرور
100 يوم على بدء الحرب وسط خلافات حاده بل
وتوبيخ نتنياهو لوزراء بارزين مثل بنفير
بعد تهديدهم بانهم لن يوافقوا على اقرار
الميزانيه ولا يتشابه كلام نتنياهو في
جلسه الحكومه تلك مع كلامه في مؤتمره في
اليوم السابق فحسب بل ان شحوب وجهه كان
نفسه حين كرر تعهده بمواصله القتال واكد
وعوده الثلاثه التي دقت طبول الحرب
الاسرائيليه على
وقعها اعاده المختطفين تدمير حماس وضمان
انلا يخرج من غزه اي تهديد بعد
اليوم لكن هذا اليوم لازال يبدو بعيدا على
الاقل من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين الذين ما
عادت عباره اليوم التالي عنوانا ثابتا في
صحفهم واعلامهم لتحل محلها تدريجيا عناوين
اخرى اقل تفاؤلا فيوم واحد بعد خطاب
نتنياهو اي في اليوم المئه للحرب تصدرت
رؤوس الصحف التي طالما روجت للحرب ودعت
لاستمرارها حتى النهايه عناوين يشتم منها
كل شيء سوى الروح القتاليه العاليه التي
حاول نتنياهو بثها فقد برز في صحيفه يدعوت
احرونوت واسعه الانتشار والتاثير عنوان هو
يتزايد الشعور بان نتنياهو يمدد الحرب
لاسباب شخصيه وفي مقاله في الصحيفه نفسها
راى الكاتب وهو خبير اسرائيلي في السياسات
والشؤون الاستراتيجيه ان التوصل لصفقه مع
وقف الحرب كليا هو احد الخيارات التي لا
مفر منها والا ستكون خشيه من حرب استنزاف
لن تخرج منها اسرائيل منتصره اما معاريف
فاور دت خبرا نقلا عن لواء في سلاح الجو
قال فيه ان التصور بانه بالامكان حسم حرب
من خلال التفوق الجوي هو تصور يجب ان
يتغير كما اجرت نفس الصحيفه استطلاعا كان
سؤاله هل توافقون على عقد صفقه لتحرير
المختطفين حتى لو كان الثمن انهاء الحرب
وبغض النظر عن نتيجه الاستطلاع فمجرد طرح
التساؤل يشي بان انتهاء الحرب لا بل
انهاؤها دون تحقق اهدافها المعلنه بات
خيارا فرض نفسه على النقاش الداخلي
الاسرائيلي اما موقع والله الاخباري فورد
خبرا يتحدث عن الدعم الامريكي عنوانه انه
بعد 100 يوم من الحرب بدا صبر رئيس بايدن
ينفد والوضع غدا كارثيا وفي حين يبدو
المشهد كذلك في التيار المركزي في المشهد
الاعلامي الاسرائيلي تظل هناك اصوات من
تيار اليمين تعزف عزف البنادق تنتقي
الاخبار والتصريحات التي ما زالت ترى في
استمرار القصف ونشر الدمار الوسيله
الوحيده لاعاده الاسرى الاسرائيليين
فموقع ص0 ا المعروف بانحيازه اليميني يركز
كالعاده على ان يكون منصه لبنغ فير رغم ان
الاخير لا ينزل عن منصه الا وقد اثار
عاصفه من تصريحات الاستنكار داخليا
وخارجيا فينقل الموقع اليوم تصريحاته
الناقده لاعضاء مجلس الحرب المصغر بعد
اعلان الانتقال لمرحله اقل حده من القتال
وحتى بخصوص قضيه المختطفين العامل الاكثر
ضغطا على حكومه نتنياهو لوقف محتمل للقتال
فيها ينقل تصريحا لوالد احد الاسرى يقول
فيه ان الضربات الثقيله لحماس هي ما سينهي
الحرب ويعيل المختطفين صوت يبدو شاذا في
وسط عائلات المختطفين الذين تتعالى
اصواتهم غضبا وسخطا مطالبين باستقاله
الحكومه وعوده المختطفين حتى لو كان الثمن
بقاء
حماس في مؤتمره الاخير استعمل نتنياهو
كعادته اقتباسا من التوراه حاول فيه شحن
الهمم ورفع المعنوي فخب الله الايه التي
جمعها من اقطار الارض ومنحها ارض اسرائيل
فقال واسوا ارضكم التي منحتها لعبدي يعقوب
واسكنها بامان وابنوا فيها البيوت وازرعوا
الكروم واذا ظن نتنياهو ان كلامه التوراتي
الداعيه لاستمرار الحرب بحر من المداد لا
ينفد فصبر الاسرائيلين كما يبدو اخذ في
التلاشي فوق صوت طبول الحرب
باتت تطغى صرخات الغضب من ضحايا الحرب
الذين غداى صمت ابنائهم المحتجزين في غزه
هو كل ما يتردد صداه في
اذانهم